vous ai réservé une petite surprise
chenneviette et claudia il est là il va
expressément pour vous à vous faire
jouer ce rappeur que vous adorez fait
son retour dans touche pas à mon pote
bien
avec thomas savare frère ou une forme
olympique
non sur la tête de ma mère je suis
tellement cottage avis de me fracturé le
nez là dans un coin de la tête et j'en
ai marre tout casser toutes les brèches
vous avez vous avez rien devraient pas
mener des plans spéciaux n'est pas s'il
ya des planchettes on verra au cas où si
tu veux au nom de ma mère pourquoi je
suis dégoûté pourquoi j'ai pris cinq
buts dans l'outaouais hier
ouais ouais contre aunis et la guérilla
et c'était chaud mon frère alors fait
tous les noms vous allez faire jouer et
rhodia tagbo et geneviève de fontenay
mais je vais prendre tous les héros 6/2
je vais démettre bien sûr narbonne tu
vas voir on doit découvrir quoi pour les
téléspectateurs au jour là aujourd'hui
on a retrouvé chansons de la fête
je vais pas des chaussons de la fête
version rap adacore de marseille free
rose essayez donc de retrouver les
chansons
attention je me suis pas fait la paix la
paix va changer de nom bien et on sait
ce qu'il va travailler la poste va
s'appeler 10,6 la poste
on joue avec des titres de la fête qui
sont remasterisés aura essayé de trouver
quel est ce procès titre et c'est parti
alors il m'a dit qu'il veut le saut
elle est née à ben laden son père et sa
mère et audi à rené pas de voir cette
info bien rose et d'autres animaux avec
un et qu'on ne voyait pas aussitôt tout
le village clip parlait déjà pour venir
fêter ce pop à thème
mais voilà il fallait trouver un surnom
moi je n'avais pas mais j'ai trouvé
comment il faut l'appeler classe voisine
de changement mais voir les capitaux de
la neige je vous trouve à pékin chine
qui m'avait tout au bout des lèvres
j'ai par tous les voisins de marie qu'il
use m'amuse beaucoup moins sur nos fans
et 4,5 ou 5 à 6
alors est ce que vous avez la réponse qu
il chantait quoi bécassine chantal à la
deuxième filtre cerrato chantal goya
ghetto mon frère alors les 12 deuxièmes
chances on voit la sauce papa est en
voyage on a subi que je fais lorsque je
m'ennuie j'ai imaginé ce complexe le
matin je changerais de cesse que tu
donnes étrange de trois grenades des
rues de foix des années 80 et fermé
jusqu'au bout des seins l'autorité et du
charme des années 80 voient que le minot
car le café chaud bien notés sur la
grappe tu veux tu peux tout rire aux
larmes
homme n'est pas tout
ttt de tenue
alors changé de côté
troisième et dernier titre c'est parti
partis frères un mois le sont ils des
classes et geneviève de fautes et tout
le ghetto dennis treuz rester
pour tous du coeur une chanson si ces
lieux car tu sais par caire qu'à ma vie
ressemble à l'autre tout sous des voiles
corps de huit hommes et jeunes plants et
encore le bruit des italiennes je t'aime
à l'italienne c'est clair
mais c'est au tour ou si tu parles à
quelle date quand les ventes us
la musica je souhaiterais rien que pour
toi
voilà
ses flingues et la tête je t'aime à
l'italienne
non non c'est pas ça et courtois
au jeu très mal
creo et merci jour et remercier notre
ami cartman bien sûr que tu as et on est
trop bien sûr demain entre 7h et 9h dans
le bordeaux dès 17h
on va te retrouver dans l'instant un
très grand talent au locle